hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
a video taking a look at one of the
slimmest most well-built ultrabooks that
you can buy right now we're taking a
look at the asus zenbook
ux31 go ahead and give it a thumbs up on
this video if you enjoy it and without
any further ado let's get right into
this one
[Music]
all right i'm gonna go ahead and start
this off by saying the zenbook ux31 is a
picture-perfect definition of an
ultrabook and in case you didn't already
know i'll include a link in the
description as zenbook in order to be
called an ultrabook needs to fit a
certain number of qualifications and
this does just that you can see it's
razor thin and it has a nice tapering
design to it from back to front but this
one separates itself from other possibly
tapering laptops check this out on the
right hand side you have a usb 3.0 port
okay 3.0
power mini vga and mini hdmi ports and a
battery charging light and on the
left-hand side you have another usb port
a headphone jack and a memory card
reader and there you can get a good look
at that nice solid tapering design so
there's nothing on the bottom of the
laptop and the battery while it's
non-removable is actually pretty good so
it wasn't a problem and the whole laptop
is this nice spun metal finish that's
just just screams
slick or something i don't know it's hot
reminds me of the transformer prime
actually
but there's no ports on the back of this
laptop either which is perfect the way
it should be so all you have is this
hinge and i can tell that asus spent
time designed it properly put the right
parts in the right places just so that
it could do
this oh
yeah boss does your laptop do that i
didn't think so okay so once you open it
up you get the keyboard the trackpad and
the screen and this is where you can
make or break it here in a laptop the
keyboard
it's alright it's not the best i've ever
used but it's definitely not the worst
there's a little bit of flex but not
much because it's metal and the size of
the keyboard was fine for even my
mammoth sized hands and there's function
keys and everything they work great with
windows the keyboard is pretty good and
the display was right on i might not be
a fan of glossy on the desktop but they
pulled it off here with a 13.3 inch 1600
by 900 ips panel the viewing angles were
decent but the screen actually gets
really really bright which is nice for
using it outdoors
and a track pad
uh
no it's just bad i mean it's a it's big
and smooth and has nice hidden buttons
and everything but for some reason mine
just wasn't that sensitive at all it was
really weird i don't know if it was just
mine or maybe too much maybe i'm a mouse
and keyboard kind of guy but i feel like
if you're getting an ultra portable
laptop you don't really want to carry
around a secondary mouse you know so the
keyboard and the trackpad should be
really top notch but this trackpad let
me down it worked okay with windows
gestures but i would have preferred a
more sensitive keyboard and trackpad i
feel like it could use a firmware update
or something so inside the beast we have
windows 7 home premium and an intel core
i5 2557m at 1.7 gigahertz so you know
what that means you can do work on this
thing it's an ultra low voltage
processor so battery lasts wow but
performance doesn't lag behind even a
split second the graphics were snappy
and it's responsive to everything i
threw at it including
editing a video while plugged in
in power mode but still um i'm convinced
that the 128 gig ssd in this laptop had
a lot to do with that also the speakers
were really loud it surprised me it kind
of blew me away actually but i'd like to
see more of the technology they used in
these speakers in more mobile devices i
liked it a lot and all this comes in a
17 millimeter thin package
i don't have to tell you which one's the
ultrabook at least i hope not peace out
guys
[Music]
you